chabada bah voila c'est une bonne
ambiance justement j'ai failli débarquer
comme ça là où ça bouge nous sommes ce
soir devant le conservatoire de région à
côté un petit peu austère et vous en
tant que nouvelle directrice j'ai
l'impression que ça va booster beaucoup
de choses claires paris avait cela on a
beaucoup discuté vous avez des goûts qui
vont de miles davis à supertramp genesis
et en passant évidemment par tous le
tout le classique c'est à dire que vous
voulez pas de frontières dans la musique
ça veut dire ça ça veut dire ça je pense
que chaque instant de ma vie à une
petite référence auditive que quand on a
envie de se retourner vers soi miles
davis et pas forcément ce que
j'écouterais en premier tir est plutôt
vers du bac
quand j'ai envie de plénitude de
grandeur j'irais plutôt vers mahler et
que j'ai envie de sauter partout et je
rejoins mes amours d'adolescente et donc
supertramp genesis totaux enfin tout ce
qui est me parle quoi
à
vous venez de roncq mais vous dites il
faut laisser aussi les enfants écouter
autre chose que du classique c c'est
assez curieux pour quelqu'un qui
s'occupe d'un concert va tourner à plus
l'habitude d'avoir des gens qui disent
non le classique école classique alors
le et que déjà je trouve que c'est
restrictif je pense qu'une grande valeur
c'est la liberté
nos enfants ou une vie dans leur iphone
et le ipod
il n'y a pas forcément que du mozart et
que du stockage zone et je veux pas
qu'il y ait de rupture je veux que cette
maison soit une maison de vie et donc je
veux qu'ils puissent se dire qu'il n'ya
pas de jugement de valeur
à écouter ou du bac ou autre chose c'est
pas grave
le principal c'est qu'ici où prennent en
compte qu'ils sont et qu'on les aide à
avancer dans le respect de leur personne
le rouge
à voir et écouter vendredi au portobello
à quand le big sister show soirée
multiculturelle avec plusieurs concerts
et même une exposition big sister chaud
il
là où ça bouge nous sommes à l'espace
coisel à saint martin de fontenay ou
centré sur ans sur les deux communes
pendant deux jours les 22 et 23 octobre
ici même concert de métal pourquoi ce
concert at il une saveur un peu
particulière
la présence de karine va va tout vous
expliquer parce que karine vous êtes là
aussi pour vous battre pour valentin oui
on a un enfant qui est malheureusement
qu à une malformation du cervelet il est
né en 2011 et pour subvenir à tout ce
qui est matériel l'achat du matériel
poussettes sièges auto
on a créé une association un sourire
pour valentin ce qui nous a permis
d'acheter effectivement début le
matériel et mon mari étant un fan de
métal main il s'est dit pourquoi pas
allier le le matériel et puis le plaisir
on alloue blast
as
à des x on aura aidé charger à
désillusion
el haimer dagoba
frantic machine primal idg killers
je crois avoir pratiquement donner tous
les noms c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup
si vous venez à l'espace coisel les 22
et 23 octobre pour écouter du métal il
faut savoir que tous les bénéfices
seront reversés à l'association un
sourire pour valentin c'est ça on est
d'accord c'est important vous allez tous
au concert conquérant métal fès le 22 et
23 octobre est ici derrière moi
demain l'auteur compositeur interprète
arnold turboust l'enfant de saint sever
qui a composé tombés pour la france pour
daho ou adélaïde sur un autre invité
pour une balade dans sa région ce saint
sever torigni sur vire et arromanches al
surtout pas manquer à demain
art